What are your thoughts on,
on alien life,
on life outside of this planet? Is
there something you think about? Yeah,
I think there must be,
um,
even in the solar system,
I would not be surprised if we find
microbes on Mars or some of the moons of
Jupiter or Saturn where there's
liquid water like Europa. Yeah.
And the reason is, if you think
about, there isn't, I think that,
and it's a guess is because if you
look at the history of life on earth,
then so earth formed and it was just, uh,
there was no life. It was a ball of rock.
And almost as soon as it cooled down,
we see evidence of life
certainly 3.8 billion years ago,
possibly even further back than that.
We see evidence of life on earth.
So somewhere along the line,
geochemistry,
active geochemistry became
biochemistry on earth.
And we have some idea, you know, the, the,
if you get a gradient of temperature
and acid and alkaline and the conditions
that are naturally present
on the surface of oceans,
then complex carbon chemistry
spontaneously happens.
So we have a,
we know that life almost certainly
we know that life began on earth.
I mean the other option is it came
from space or something like that,
but probably didn't.
It probably began on earth.
And so that means that at least here
that happened and that we know that the
conditions that led to the origin of life
on earth were present a 3.8 4 billion
years ago. And we know that
they're present on Europa today.
So I don't see that
there's anything special.
Life is just chemistry
and it, and, and the,
the idea that Geo chemistry becomes
biochemistry is not fanciful because it
happened here.
So I think that given the same conditions,
it will be surprising to me at the same
thing didn't happen in that life begins.
So I,
that's one of the test that is one
of the great frontiers of science.
Now.
It's one of the great challenges,
which is why we're another reason we're
interested in Mars because we know those
conditions were there.
We know there were what's called
hydrothermal vent systems on the floors of
oceans.
Our mouths 3.8 or 4 billion years ago.
So it will be good to know what
I've said is right and they're,
the way we find out is to find
life or evidence of past life.
Are you aware of uh, the speculation
that was going around? What,
how recent was it? That
occupy thing? The uh,
the octopus eggs,
they,
there was a group of scientists that
were speculating that it's Po, you know,
Panspermia the idea of Panspermia that
it's possible that Octopi had come from
somewhere else. I'm frozen eggs. It
actually come from somewhere else and,
and landed on earth and there's just
like legitimate scientist or contemplated
not morons. I don't think I've
seen this. The, no, I didn't,
but I mean I think so. Panspermia doesn't
have to be unlikely. I mean, for example,
you might have seen the other day we
found an earth rock on the moon. Right?
Well they'll let your back
on earth now cause he,
Apollo astronauts brought it back then
there is 4 billion years old or something.
Like one of the oldest rocks
ever found. Yeah. Right. So,
so we know that material gets
transferred between planets. Um,
and so it's not inconceivable
that microbes could survive
that journey. Right.
We know that microbes can
survive in space, for example.
So that isn't mad. Uh, is probably
unlikely, but he's not mad.
But with the octopus,
I hadn't heard that.
But the thing is that the octopus is still
extremely similar biologically to us.
I mean the differences are negligible.
So he still got the same energy system
with a single ATP and DNA and all that
stuff. It's all very, very similar.
It was something about RNA and DNA.
Did you to find that out
girl? I'm trying. If I'm looking at
different one from a different website,
it's about the same thing it has to do
with the Cambrian explosion. And there,
there are 33 authors on a paper that
got published in the progress and of in
biophysics and molecular biology
that talked about this possibility.
There are other people that
disagree with it though,
right? I mean, yeah, I suppose
the, I haven't seen it.
So I think it's unlikely because the
octopus is extremely similar to us.
So that suggests a common origin to
me that's oppose the cancer argument.
You could, you could advance would
be, there's only one way to do life.
So you could say that actually given,
because the laws of physics and
chemistry the same everywhere.
So maybe it's maybe DNA
is the only way to do it.
So that's the way it gets done,
which is why they're so similar to us.
All those so alien as well. Yeah,
they, they're not though. You know,
that's the thing about it.
Not so that's why I'm surprised a value
because they're not the alien that
they're very similar while
they're in their abilities.
I mean their ability to transform their
outer outer texture and their color
almost instantaneously.
Oh yeah.
I mean they have incredible camouflage
abilities that really don't exist.
And the Ma'am Mammalian world.
Yeah. But on a cellular level,
you look at an ox for sal
and among under a microscope,
and you wouldn't be able to tell the
dean she knocks per cell and humans.
So the only way that that would make
sense as if all life comes from basically
the same kind of building blocks.
And just varies depending upon the
conditions and where it takes place.
I'm I'm guessing, but yes,
that that must be the,
there the only way you could sustain
that given that they're so similar to us
because they really are biochemically is
that that's the only way it can be done
given the given the building block, the
toolkit, the laws of nature and the,
the elements and so on that
we have in our universe,
we have so many different
life forms on our planet,
but if we found anything that's remotely
similar to what we have here on earth,
on another planet, it would be such an
incredible discovery. Like when we sat,
if we found a frog on the moon, I mean
there was, the world would stop. Right.
I'd be very surprised they
were in the car going to me.
What I mean if we're found anything,
anywhere that is any in any
way similar an insect on Mars?
Well this is, I mean as I say, it'd be
micro. I think we single celled things.
Remember, I mean, you mentioned
the Cambrian explosion.
So that is that what we do that earth is,
although life began,
let's say 3.8 billion years ago,
it wasn't until around 600
million years ago or so,
or maybe most 700 that you see any
complex multicellular organisms.
That's all.
So for something like 3 billion years,
it was single celled alone,
and that's one of the reasons why
I would guess, if I had to guess,
I would say that microbes would be
common because life began very quickly on
earth. And I wouldn't be surprised
to find it on Mars, but complex life,
multicellular life,
insects, plan intelligence,
I would guess would be very rare because
it took so long on earth to get there
and you just slime for 3
billion years of slime.
That was it.